le podcast est une présentation de
l'électronique cycling association er à
un organisme à but non lucratif axée sur
la réutilisation de matériels
électroniques désuets tout le monde on a
toujours des du matériel électronique
qui nous sert plus moi par exemple qu'un
recherche de l'iphone etc si j'avais
encore un iphone 6 mais je voulais pas
le donner ou le ventre de peur que mes
données se ramasse dans les mains de
l'acheteur donc le héros offre un
service d'effacement la destruction
physique des données dont vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous soucier d'être durant
la qu'ovide ils ont mis sur place un
programme qui permettait d'aider les
gens qui devaient faire du télétravail
et ou de l'école à la maison mais qui
avaient pas les moyens de s'offrir du
matériel électronique adéquat donc ils
ont eu plus de 1200 de membres durant là
que vit le programme existe encore
maintenant donc vous pouvez aller voir
ça pour plus d'information erp à point c
à puis là avec la rentrée il offre
plusieurs concours pour gagner soit des
ordinateurs ou soit une bourse d'études
donc fait aussi aller voir ça sur leur
site web le ra point ca
et si vous avez des objets ou du
matériel électronique désuet mais vous
pouvez vous assurer de leur laisser en
fait en appelant au 1 8 7 7 9 3 9 2 7 8
3 et toutes ces informations là encore
une fois sont sur leur site web le ra
point ca donc si vous voulez planifier
une cueillette au avoir plus
d'informations vous savez où aller voir
ça merci la gamme du 1er à puis à
prochaine tout le monde
une production du studio sf mélo sans
filtre le buzz car si on parle de ce
qu'on veut nous inviter d'attitude plage
quand tu es avec moi deux plantes
si vous voulez nous encourager le maire
la meilleure façon de le faire
en fait c'est d'aller vous inscrire à
notre pétrole après chaque épisode on
fait encore moins de filtres ou si on
discute de la conversation qu'on vient
d'avoir avec nicky nicole nico nicolas
est principalement nicole qui derrière
la console fait qu allez vous inscrire à
notre pays
la déception est le lien pour ça c'est
clémence mungroo journée encore épuisé
le lien vers cette plateforme là pour
nous encourager et dans la description
du podcast sinon aujourd'hui l'homme
aujourd'hui on reçoit rose aimée autant
de témoins non qu'ici comme un poème
oui tout à fait une fille une femme
complètement
brillante vraiment un grand plaisir de
parler avec elle là comme la
conversation on a commencé à parler
avant le début du podcast du phénomène
des écopes artistes ces personnes là qui
donne des conseils de drague de cruz aux
autres hommes en termes de conférences
puis c'est pas souvent dans un angle
féministe d'un onglet respectueux donc
aussi ça le couvert la voix var var les
conversations sur la sensualité de
sensualité des hommes et aussi la
séduction a aujourd'hui en 2020 comment
ça va commencer comment ça se déroule
vraiment d'une conversation sur la
sexualité en général c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est vraiment le sujet de
prédilection de rose aimée et puis à
personne aussi mais parler de
conspirationnisme c'est quelque chose en
ce moment qui qui qui assomme du présent
je pense que sur les réseaux sociaux il
ya beaucoup d'informations parfois plus
douteuses qui y circulent puis et
beaucoup de gens dans leur entourage
qu'ils font vos spectacles pour cette
assemblée la tuque qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec ces gens là qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec nous mêmes on on on se met à en
croire ces choses là je pense que c'est
apprendre sais pas s'il n'est pas à
prendre à la légère
qui sait ce qu'est ce qu'on fait que ces
gens là je pense que c'est important de
l'adresser puis de voir ça comme un vrai
phénomène inquiétant quand même un
plaisir tout acheter les choses n'ont
cessé c'était une super conversation
osée mais qui est extrêmement allumé
puis qui nous qui est capable de très
bien exprimer ses opinions puissent et
point de vue puis elle avait aussi
autant que nous des questions plus que
plus ce qui est des questions que de
réponses comme dans lé tout le monde en
ce moment je pense que c'est ce qui se
passe dans nos vies 2020 est une année
remplie de questionnements mais si
nécessaire l'important c'est d'avoir des
conversations comme celle qu'on a donc
sans plus attendre
on vous laisse l'écouté donc bon podcast
bonne écoute
[Musique]
en continuant je suis l'homme la
conversation pour urban iott a eu un
entrevue avec un pick up artist c'est
quoi un peu cow boys nathan c'est
quelqu'un qui donne des trucs pour
séduire les femmes
mais comme s'il existait finalement une
recette unique contre appliqué sur à peu
près n'importe qui conduit
il existe un paquet de stratégie mais en
général on cherche et le jeu suit la
personne majeure je pense que tout ça on
cherche à stimuler le cerveau est
ancestrale parce que le problème c'est
que nous on a un c'est rule qui est
acquis des notions là par exemple
d'égalité mais oui voilà mais
heureusement au fond il reste notre
savoir strahl qui a besoin est d'après
challenge et est sauvé évidemment parce
qu'on est des pauvres jeunes femmes donc
le truc en gros des pick up artist est
de déstabiliser la source de leur désir
comme lui faire perdre ses repères ses
outils actuels puis revenir à la source
donc de ce qu'est la femme est elle j'ai
fait une entrevue donc avec un coach en
séduction parce que c'est un genre de
l'humour où son mari un conférencier
leurs profs se décrit comme la
définition du mettant les pick up artist
ils vont dire bon set féloche à trouver
je voulais dire à son ami je veux donner
de l'intérêt à son ami comme ça va
sentir que c'est pas ma source
d'attention pierre va vouloir se battre
pour avoir enfoncé intentions parce que
c'est comme ça les femmes évidemment où
elle je vais miser sur ses complexes et
donc eh ouais j'ai jamais vue des jeux
c'est peut-être déjà remarqué que t'as
jamais vraiment croche se mettant
quelque chose de zéro c'est du simple la
personne n'a été bousculée va perdre
confiance en elle que ça va être toi qui
veux revenir la sauver j'avais fait une
entrevue avec un conférencier parce que
je voulais savoir en quoi ces
conférences avaient changé depuis les
mouvements de dénonciations d'abus
sexuels on en parle c'est sûr que la
ligue ont parlé séduit parce que bon ils
vont se faire accuser
ok mais c'est toi en tant que
conférencier ton approche a dû réfléchir
elle à la séduction s'est rendus croit
aujourd'hui honnêtement j'allais là de
bonne foi mais vraiment savoir l'autre
réfléchi à tout ça
puis ç'a vraiment détourné après sa
soeur séduire des féministes puis
mexique et qui avait des catégories de
féministes comme quatre catégories
les deux premières sont possibles par
sont récupérables mais après ça en gros
c'est ses défauts lui ont soufflé oui
exact la vie oui j'espère que j'ai avec
avec des stratégies c'est d'efforts
exactement et et le problème clé
féministe que notre âme seconds rôles
tout le temps ça qu'on peut pas se
rendre au cerveau ancestrale métissé
notre perte au fond là parce que c'est
une houle qui se privant de cyber leur
relation qui au début j'avais manqué sa
webcam chicane au bout d'une heure je
commence à être un peu lourde avril
oui oui on est au téléphone qui est mon
conjoint dans la même pièce est fort il
est en train de zschopau il fait quelque
chose sur le devant côté et vient un
moment je pèse vraiment repris du plan
hockey mais moi je crois une femme
lestés de type 3 mais je peux pas mal
fort et qu'ils veulent pareil comment tu
expliques sow et le monde change
heurtaux qui me regarde pas ce que ce
qu'il fait en train de faire une
entrevue professionnel qui me fait des
drôles des yeux
les conférenciers comme chanceuse où il
ya des gars qui sont prêts à faire des
compromis
yabiladi pas même univers que toi puis
cabindais oui vie dans le même univers
qui est beaucoup dire si souvent sonia
comprend pas les acteurs sociaux mise et
là je me dis parfait donc il ya beaucoup
de conception sur l'intimité et qui est
des discours qui sont très valide et
tenus de manière massive qui moi même ni
tout bas c'est sûr nous avons fait à
partir de maintenant j'ai un bout de
chemin à faire et il y en a probablement
un hiatus moyens d'avoir une discussion
je pars en train de péter une coche il
dirige toujours et qui je vois comme on
peut j'ai ma part de temps maintenant
mais c'est surtout tellement éclairant
de acquis et beaucoup de gens ce qu'ils
pensent qu'une fille
ça doit exister faut séduire en
manipulant en gros comme si c'était tout
est dans le camp de ceux qui parce que
ce genre de rapports sociaux là doivent
changer et évoluer puis celle inverse
lui si oui c'est une atteinte à à même
son identité bien sinon le gamin la
charge mais c'est parce que c'est une
vision de la masculinité aussi l'exemple
l'homme doit chasser et toute femme ont
envie d'en être chassés puis ci dessus
si je réussis pas attraper avec mais
drôle de stratégie alors le problème
c'est que tu réfléchis trop c'est une
vision très biologie de l'amour forêt de
la nature humaine et gasperini faire
déshabiller mais maitient mettons sur
les pick up artist puis cette idée là
maintenant dans le l'enseigné ppi prix
che a déjà ça c'est un autre niveau
maintenant si tu descends juste un petit
peu le niveau pee de comment on en est
et nous les premiers
on sait pas pas enseigner mais comment
on a appris à la séduction c'est quand
même sur le spectre des chicanes dans
les livres de pick up artist le dans
certains articles des peco poétesse
qu'on peut retrouver ces choses-là
laitiers on en avait parlé de ces
mesures le mettons le concept qu'on
appelait le beach shield fait qu steak
techniquement une fille qui était belle
dans un bar à mettet son beach schild
qui a sabordé tout le temps fait
qu'avant voilà toute froide et qui de ce
côté là si vous réussissez à briser ce
qui y est
maintenant ça c'est comme un concept
dans lequel on a comme ses cavaliers
fait que les gens l'aient fait que tu
t'intéresses aucun désigne hop tu leur
fasse en tout cas si l'adresse est là
pour les pour briser ce métier ça c'est
comme un concept qui était pratiquement
acquis dans la façon avec laquelle on ne
grandit on a évolué dans le traitement
facilement en fait c'est toutes ces
constructions là pour moi c'est insensé
quelque intérêt si c'est pour ça que moi
je suis tout le temps comme le
consentement c'est sexy qu'elle fait
dans un bar ferez pas contents de se
farder je veux vraiment peu de déranger
je te trouve magnifique mois dans ce
coin là si jamais sa tente de parler le
bail personnes buy com voshix viens pas
me parler testant team aujourd'hui s'ils
savaient pas vu une foule de force mais
ça a été le moment le plus humiliant
toute ma vie pourquoi mais parce que
toute la soirée comme j'étais avec des
amis bien une fille que je trouvais
vraiment belle puis on tire on parle est
un petit pays comme sa valeur déclic et
la france je regardais amie choquée je
crois les avoir
puis je voyais du rire comment est ce
que j'ai ressenti le j-10 j'allais avoir
planté dans un bar fictives
je m'approche un peu de blush paycheck
je suis vraiment pas bon dans un
contexte mort mais comme à première vue
tu m'intéresse vraiment beaucoup
j'aimerais qu'on n'aille pas en avoir
oui pleine mesure qu les halos juste
éclaté de rire fait partie j'ai fait ça
vienne me détruire la réception ça peut
pas fonctionner tout le temps
visiblement les prix ce que des bas mais
certainement plus sain que des aulas
film intéresse je vais faire semblant
qui m'intéresse pas prêt sonné comme un
saison bien compliquée séduit chez peau
et même s'il faut faire semblant que la
personne ne m'intéresse pas ouf autres
jouer des tours de magie fried aussi
sont un truc d'un truc de pick up ont
attiré l'intérêt de la personne si on
revenait juste au baltique à la franche
et par rapport aux conférences
je comprends qu'ils aient un besoin de
conférenciers par exemple
je peux prête à jeter aux poubelles
l'idée d'un conférencier en séduction
c'est je pense qu'il ya plein de gens
qui sont en perte de repères en ce
moment puisque seulement devraient
manger tue le droit d'aborder quelqu'un
comment on fait une question de
confiance en soi aussi
je trouve ça cool des hommes qui se
rassemblent entre eux pour parler d'eux
j'ai de la misère à aborder les filles
pourquoi ces français armand je me
dirais je suis pour les coaches
d'exposition c'est quand il ya un manque
de respect pour les femmes ou un manque
de considération pour l'assister la
société qui change les codes qui évolue
où l'on moi j'ai un problème mais gaulé
comme l'éducation c'est l'éducation
sexuelle golta entre mais c'est autre
chose ici comment justement où j'ai un
ami qui était qui est tombé dit pas tout
les livres pillay il est pratiqué ce
petit rhume et on est sorti le calcul
des points à me présenter dans les bars
souvent pis c'était comme typiques 10
foot face de plus en plus le site comme
un entraînement titres qui sortent et
puis même s'il faisait acheter ce n'est
pas grave que cela n'entraîne maps et
comme tu suivras à chaque fois avec
l'outil lui il y presque ces trucs tout
un langage c'est vraiment un répertoire
de deux de pique à plein par répertoire
piste -comme c'est pas grave si tu dis
n'importe quoi la personne qui m'a
complètement laissé s'est dit encouragé
le titre pâtisse pas grave le prêt porte
les moyens qui étoit arrivé foot arrive
à des frais mentalement
une caricature de mahomet il ya même des
gueux qui doivent pas être même proche
de cette caricature le pitti ça ça le
titille bâton et avec tout ce qui s'est
passé récemment le monde réfléchit mythe
et je mets ton si ton faire accroire à
la personne mettant la fille te dis moi
ce que je recherche c'est une relation
sérieuse
knight et moi aussi non mais ils
prennent des gens qui font ça on aime
aussi le tpiy je trouve ramacker une
belle couche avec la personne disparaît
ça arrive souvent ne suis horrifié ça
souvent imputés à quel point tu essaies
city mettant un leader politique te dire
hey good job les foules depuis le
pointage web un système de pointage
c'est comme si tu réussis le stop à
varennes le personnellement je les
pollutions été référé mais c'était comme
si tu rentres dans un morse sur réussi à
aborder un groupe de filles qui sont
dans ce centre reçoit les aborder savent
autant points
si tu réussis à french une feuille
soudain soir ça autant pour impulser com
afin d'assurer du chèque ton pointage
qui garde un genre de carnets ton
pointage de la soirée frottez c'est
d'améliorer son pointage à chaque fois
que sort tout seul dans un bar c'est une
sortir du seul en avoir pour aller faire
cette sortie animée depuis l'été avec m
quand tu rentres dans le bar ce moment
et ouvre la porte faut que tu es très
attention sur toi tu fasses de couette
flamboyant pour monter c'est un mâle
dominant était juste rentrer dans ce
genre lots qu'il faut que tu fasses de
quoi plaire et louise des marques dit le
code réduction que j'avais interviewé
pour urbanien il m'avait expliqué que
faute autant que l'homme arrive 20
minutes avant et là sont pas sa
partenaire dans une première lettre
parce que c'est son territoire là qu'il
faut qu'ils comprennent qu'ils sont 30
plus partout et la bonne banque et
l'autre approché au fil de la soirée
pour faire un premier contact physique
hakim existe pas complètement fou que
correct reset merlet je suis de bonne
foi après il faut que tu parles aux
serveurs ou à la serveuse aussi parce
que va falloir que tu ne déstabilise pas
d'être vraiment de la facture le cheikh
kifak tacle tu t'arranges avec le sperme
voix rauque et pour que tu y as même pas
de questions de première ou deuxième
facture ou qu'il ya une ambiguïté
mekhissi qu'est ce que tu vas répondre
parce que c'est ta première pièce est
une pièce de théâtre est plus chère à
qui la séduction est une pièce de
théâtre mais il ya des gens je crois
qu'ils ont besoin de jouer un personnage
parce qu'ils sont tellement ébranlé non
leur confiance en eux ou dans un monde
en changement que c'est peut-être plus
facile d'incarner un personnage que j'ai
pas envie de tirer des boulets sur les
gens qui vont chercher encore j'ai
besoin de faire au québec hebdo
allemand on peut juste prendre un peu de
recul sera assurée par des humains qui
fera en compte des fois ça marche des
fois ça marche papier tout un homme mais
nommons les jo ça va être puissant à
quel point c'est certain que ça te
revient dans la phase un jour ou l'autre
bakel fouet non mais mais si mettons ce
que tu veux vraiment pas le ladakh et
c'est pas juste ça m'a couché qu'une
fille serait quelqu'un puisse faire une
blonde mais si c'est celui ci s'est
basée sur des mensonges d'en face un
jour ou l'autre côté il ya des gens qui
vivent des mensonges très longtemps le
france au bowling ou une carrière
ces gens qui ont faim sans doute d'avoir
quelques et des syriens
il est vraiment proche de moi qui a été
pendant deux ans et demi une personne
qui vivent un mensonge complet mentaires
surtout sur son sa ville de naissance
sur ces affaires diplôme qui était comme
ses amis autour il quand il courait
encore à bord s ces informations là
parce qu'ils connaissent et l'ait fait
qu'ils aient jacky emon oui c'est vrai
penelope mais je connais deux personnes
- qui ont été en couple avec quelqu'un
qui avait une deuxième vie sans vraiment
savoir le pendant des années puis par
deuxième vie je peux dire avoir un amant
une amende que je veux dire comme avoir
une autre maison puis un job qui est
peau celle qu'on disait qu'il avait
bluffé foods dont tous ont donc je pense
qu'il ya des gens qui peuvent vraiment
vivre dans le mensonge qui mène
probablement qu'ils sont bien là dedans
mais mon but c'est effrayant qui à quel
point je suis content d'avoir trop
confiance en moi pour est une cible de
tirs
mais en même temps jusqu'à biarritz peut
être que ça fonctionnerait je suis
ouverte aux surprises
essayez vous quelqu'un en nombre il y
avait il y avait une ligne vraiment
marqué c'est vraiment comme ça démontre
à quel point tout et rogne avec ce
processus le puits ça disait pis le je
m'excuse pour le mariage puis je le
dirai qu'un accent anglais vraiment
dommage mais c'était à l'époque romaine
tout à richmond
oui parce qu'évidemment nous on n'a pas
de désir donc c'est impossible d'entrer
en relation sexuelle avec nous parce que
ça nous tente non nécessairement c'est
parce que tu as trouvé mes failles que
justement c'est juste l'effort oui
- évidemment fait l'amour avec mes
blessures et non pas avec mes hormones
tellement la farce c'est que ça va
profondément ses profondes dans dans la
société c'était ce problème là je pense
qu'on refuse de voir la femme comme un
être sexuel de ballons depuis toujours
facile je pense que pour faire l'amour
est avec nous il faut que tu joues de
psychologie puis que tu ailles jouer
avec notre complexe des lectrices ben ça
en dit long sera quel point tu es
incapable d'accepter que moi j'ai
peut-être juste envie de fous rires
c'est inimaginable c'est donc
nécessairement va falloir que tu
manipules pour m'amener dans un lit
parce que ça pourrait pas à une de mon
propre chef les fesses dit que ce groupe
une fiche ensemble le gogo oui oui oui
[Rires]
bravo je vais te donner entre nous
jamais sans doute on vraiment baissé ce
exactement toulalan qui on est fatigué
pour le juste un siècle pour enfants thé
ou pourra être là votre disposition
c'est ça me fait capoter donc on sait
seulement on accepter la sexualité
féminine la communication puis juste
juste ce que j'ai dit je suppose au
maire de mon vivant
mais ce moment c'est pourquoi je milite
en général puis j'entends donner des
exemples concrets pour donner aux
pauvres
moi on m'a toujours très très bien
courtisé dans la vie dix sur dix a à peu
près tout le monde de lugos vraiment
gentil merveilleux rempli de
consentement et de belle approche bien
des fois les briques une des voix les
plus hautes que j'ai vue dans ma vie et
je travaillais avec quelqu un qui arrête
pas de faire des blagues sexuelles à mon
école puis ça me faisait rire le stade
était dans la bonne amie c'était
vraiment corps et qu'il y avait aucun il
y avait aucune dénonciation à faire le
jeu drôle puis un moment je sais pas ce
que c'est 100 % des blagues sur mes je
t'ai tout à fait à l'aise là dedans puis
un jour je suis un petit peu de
soultrait sol puis
je regarde notre personnel pendant que
kim parents pied fait même désir
je le vois dans tes yeux j'ai réussi tu
me disais j'ai vu ce we meet en souriant
mais je sais comme ouais mais en même
temps ce moment je les ai vraiment
n'importe quoi
ces personnels partir et macolin attaque
simoneau investi le front enfin on se
revoit lundi au bureau jamais rien passé
avec cette personne ne jamais et cette
personne là le jour où a vu un intérêt
de ma part le nommer au jeu fait route
sur dix est il content comme si c'était
noël juste nommé la chose au entendu ma
réponse des dix est pas là et se
tonifier seul mot la mettre dans un taxi
fin de l'histoire je mets des landes ans
c'est la preuve que tu peux courtiser
une collègue tu peux y faire des blagues
je m'impose une courte est vraiment
pitch peut nommer le désir quand tu veux
je pense que c'est la conséquence est ce
la clé la clé de tous pas de tout ce
qu'on entend dernièrement d'affaires
assez troublante qui vont au-delà de ce
seul mais je pense que juste la
transparence puis d'être capable de
nommer les choses d'en parler
ouvertement sur sortie du début à la fin
et le poggio quand ces quatre rendu dans
la chambre à coucher
du début à la fin de nommer les choses
de dire écoute moi je me sens comme ceux
maintenant de réactions à partir et tu
te sens comme tu veux par rapport à moi
je veux juste exprimer quand même moi je
me sens maintenant ça arrête le ty
wishart klaus a continué ou quoi que ce
soit mais j'ose avoir cette conversation
l'adulte on dirait que on dirait
tellement que c'est pas comme ça qu'on
fait les choses dans ce moment qu'on
sait que quelqu'un qui ferait ça des
fois j'allais je pense que c'est comme
ça qu'on devrait communiquer évidemment
mais comme toi il ya une occasion qui à
backfire moi ça m'est arrivé une
occasion qui bac faille et aussi quand
même récemment québec fallait pas non
plus à tourner comme moi j'aurais jamais
dû nous limiter à coup je te casser à ce
héros qui je parle avec quelqu'un sur un
message mais ton qui laisse à personne
le me lance l'invitation à l'a rejointe
oui puis le jeudi jusqu'à comme théorie
ça soit oui j'aime mieux le dire
maintenant écoutez moi ce moment je dis
chapeau à une position j'ai pas envie de
genre de relation j'ai pas envie que je
dois dire que ce soit avec personne si
nolan a laissé comme whaou genre tu
penses que tu es au matériau ne sais
vraiment pas si vous voulez dire non
mais j'en tu penses vraiment en plus je
déconne
ok je pense que c'est une réaction que
nous les femmes on reçoit constamment
j'ai de l'empathie mais moi est bon le
nom de dechy le nombre de fois où un
groupe qui connaît moyens décrits que ça
serait fun quand il prendre un verre
promettons tout répond avec plaisir mais
je connais pas ses intentions je joue
uniquement que c'est moche en coupe puis
cissé a mis quatre entreprises est belle
c'est sur ces amicales voyant un succès
certes et comme non mais dites moi
comment écrire comme 2h15 du matin
d'avoir mal mais c'est drôle comment la
seconde où on précise nous nos
intentions tout le temps comme el aaraj
d'high tone frêche c'est vrai que ça je
m'excuse d'avoir ri mais c'est tellement
une réaction que je connais bah oui mais
en même temps tant mieux si c'est pas
grave ça bah non pitié dans le fond vous
remue que ça soit clair manach la
communication difficile et que ces
personnes le guide attire mais en même
temps c'est ce qui comprend rapidement
dans quoi tu t'embarques en fonction
aussi d'être de la réaction de la
personne je dis ça prenait un peu plus
rapidement que prévu selon la presse
marié c'est vrai c'est vrai pipi mais
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que ça le
répète juste plus accepter de ne plus
accepter plus enseigner plus puisque
c'est la transparence dans tout est dans
autant méthode qui apparaît dans une
relation des sites
j'aime pas le mot terme est d'établir un
petit peu les balles sur laquelle la
relation existe pis tout ce flux tulle
et weeds est à produire des dépôts de
matériaux et après 4 dead te demande en
mariage ce serait les jurés on tient au
ses portes les relations c'est ça change
ces mouvances corée mais après ça je
trouve que jouer dans le non dit parce
que c'est supposément plus sexy c'est
une grave erreur s'il est cette espèce
de gamed de
mais le flou artistique la hauteur des
relations la has pour mourir au nom de
l'intérêt spot est vraiment juste une
amie mais je crois au sol dans un bar du
chili jeudi finalement qu'au fond je
suis maman qui était comme à huy o'keefe
active notre relation amicale sur
laquelle je pense à rien d'autre parce
que rester a soudainement changé
ce soir quand tout est clair le comme tu
es mon ami mais je t'ai déjà trouvé qu
au tout les jeux je vis mieux dans ce
type de relation le que dans tout ce qui
est enseigné dans les films d'ados puis
les conférences mois puis c'est que là
où il ya des dérapages c'est quand tu
penses que justement ce que les avances
à une fille pis c'est pas réceptive des
fois c'est jusqu'à cache ses intentions
donc le devient en mode belle je vois la
convaincre d'enfants je le sais qu'à
vous même si elle veut pas que ça
paraisse
c'est là que ça devient wipi en tabarnak
c'est parce que cette idée que d'y
renoncer parce qu'on veut que legault
travaille plus fort utile mais peut-être
que c'est vrai pour certaines personnes
mais chez moi je préfère réveiller dans
un monde où on assume que c'est pas le
même la majorité des cas le problème
fondamental de toutes les
représentations du courtisent âge
depuis le début la culture populaire que
je consomme mettons le début j'ai
commencé à consoler la culture populaire
c'est les deux se trouve ciudad le goff
pocock plus les fous qui regagne la fdt
et entier à commencer par juste at-on
dit chose que je déteste de toile
la prémisse de deux choses que j'étais à
toi c'est le guide fait payer pour
séduire l'a fait il ya séduit il faut
coop qui a regagné à prêter c'est
toujours lui s'impose picchi puis on lem
le protagoniste cyclades juillet
tellement sacoche il est tellement beau
et tellement faim oui mais c'est
précisément sur c'est toujours toujours
sa piste d'où l'importance d'avoir de
nouveaux personnages féminins et
masculins dont charles tout temps que
les personnages féminins dans les films
grand public sont souvent je s'axer sur
la relation amoureuse un excellent cru
exactement par jamais d'autre chose que
l'homme et tout ça est vrai qu'il faut
que ça change mes personnages masculins
skate accueillir chez toi si les teignes
aussi je pense c'est des personnages qui
parlent en gueule de leur intérêt
amoureux qui parlant de la fois où ça
backfire lippi qui qui qui parlent de
leurs émotions de leurs parents aussi
d'entrer en communication avec quelqu'un
moi j'ai capoté sur la série no no de
pippo est qui qui dispense gratuitement
dans le tout point tv anglo puis parce
que pour une rare fois en voyant un
personnage masculin qui est vulnérable
et très fort à la fois et qui est 100%
dans le consentement dans ses relations
sexuelles mais d'une manière sexy jeu
dira ce pitch et contrairement en fin
voici un exemple d'une masculinité
autres qui pauvre type aux toxiques mais
qui est pas qui est qui qui sont pour sa
virilité je pense que des hommes qui ont
peur de perdre leur virilité puis c'est
quelque chose que je pourrais jamais
comprendre
évidemment mais je vais respecter cette
crainte le plus d'un modèle d'homme de
décrire mais avec une sensibilité
capable d'exprimer puis de cacher des
choses parce que c'est normal d'avoir un
jardin d'essai mais faut voir des hommes
se parler entre eux à l'écran pipi dans
les bars et par tous les hommes se
parlent ouais ouais puis d'un point de
vue plus c'est maintenant mais dans
l'idée l'idée mérite que ça la
masculinité toxiques mais l'idée de la
la virilité pis de la fragilité de cette
vérité de cette grippe
virilité le puits que tu peux pas être
viril par exemple site est attiré par un
autre homme qui n'est pas être viril 6
t'es pas t'es pas poilu pipi tf a rejeté
cette idée là et est une construction
sociale à 100 pour ça mais oui puis moi
il ya un phénomène en tout cas un
phénomène je sais pas si je peux dire ça
mais il ya une tendance que je remarque
sur les réseaux sociaux et qui me fait
triper en ce moment j'ai remarqué que
dans les gens que je suis un petit
bassin se pose pour rigoureusement
scientifique ce que je veux dire
il ya de plus en plus d'hommes qui mène
des photos sexy 2 puis vraiment super
sexy viril qui jouait avec plusieurs
versions de la virilité mais qui
prennent des photos en temps comme tu
vois que c'est leur masculinité qu'il
laisse transparaître dans les photos des
sites illégaux qui ont des physiques de
raymond barre haute garonne qui n'ont
rien à un peu leur dénominateur commun
c'est qu'ils sont gays puis là j'en
parlais avec mon chum et moi ces photos
là ça me fait triper je trouve tellement
baugé trouve tellement c'est que j'y
trouve tellement affirmé ça me fait
penser un peu à tout le monde le
mouvement est pas dit positive féminin
cette sensualité le je la trouve
trippante parce que je vois rarement des
hommes qui décident eux mêmes de ces
objectifs de se faire sensuelle pour
revendiquer quelque chose jamais
pourquoi ils sont aussi gai comme et
pourquoi mes amis hétéros il n'y a pas
de photos sexy 2 sur instagram et non
pas que je crois que tout le monde
devrait mettre des photos sexy mais
pourquoi ce que je vois et revendiquer
une virilité différentes ou très
normative le pourquoi ils sont tous gays
qu'est ce qui empêche les hommes hétéros
de déjouer de leur quartier de leur sex
appeal imagine t on entend déjà passé
une première fois à travers est
différente
et puis à travers ce processus de
d'affirmation de briser les lits les
normes puis donc j'imagine que si
c'était plus facile naturel pour eux
parce que j'avoue que ce mouvement le
jeu les plus vues jeu
ai pas encore vus puis c'est vrai que
maintenant tu le dis pourquoi on en voit
plein sur instagram des filles des
femmes avec différents corps dégagent
escalopes je m'assume je le trouve beau
voilà dégueuler sur gueule tu vas en te
donne ces dégâts avec une chaîne qui
répond à tous les stands doit cesser les
dégâts justement un peu plus wade veut
qu'un autre type de cas farah et voici
mon corps putanges et l'assument jallet
puis le trouve beau je parle des gens
issus de la communauté quiz lgbt qu'il
ya de plus c'est donc moi je me dis
qu'est ce qu'il reste un gros noeud le
chinois méritent et pouvoir réaffirmé la
virilité sont sous toutes ses formes
bien cesser d'accepter qui on est aussi
plus le pouvoir que chacun e puisse
course est dommage si certaines
personnes l'ignoble autant que je trouve
ça magnifique de voir des gens de la
communauté queer faire face quoi je m'en
fous d'un stand or mon sex appeal je
vous le mettre en pleine face si vous me
demandez même un peu mais ma partie puis
je vais en profiter
puis moi je suis vraiment la plus grande
femme de soldes je trouve ça beau mais
en même temps je pense que on parle de
moins en moins là c'est ce qu'on sait
moins fait dire voici coque était
absolument avoir pu voici pour réussir
tu as besoin d'un tel genre de cas si
oui le leem ados justement de bobettes
ils ont un corps mais quand je vois ça
je me dis pas il faut absolument j'ai ce
col de ceyssat montré que le môle où la
pression sociale du corps parfait
il est sans doute moins forte oui oui
ben oui mais pas activement un chèque
pas être chez nous dans une chaise à ses
droits puis réfléchir sur wii mais oui
ce tome est un concept qui c'est un
concept qui est et qui se décline sous
plusieurs idées j'ai l'impression sur
plusieurs thématiques tu mets ton il ya
le
c'est difficile d'avoir le jeu réfléchir
vraiment à voir
difficile de voir quels sont les aspects
problématiques qui sont les aspects qui
me font moi me sentir bien dans ma peau
oui mais ton de dire à cech de la peine
mais manque le petit ça moi je trouve
que ça c'est problématique
après ça l'aspect de dire par exemple il
ya quelque chose qui est difficile c'est
juste le prendre sur toi puis va de
l'avant moi je trouve que ce c'est
quelque chose qui me ce qui m'attend
promoteurs qui me semble assez difficile
de saisir toutes les nuances de qu'est
ce qu'est vraiment la masculinité il
était là mais la portion sans suivi la
messe - vraiment c'est parce que nous en
tant que femme je pense pouvoir parler
au plus grand nombre et on se fait
demander très rapidement le de réfléchir
à notre sex appeal
il faut être sexy faut pas être trop
sexy non plus mais quoique désirable
tout le temps des erreurs parce que de
toute façon on a une date de péremption
alors que des 40 tomes personnes nous
regardent et puis ça va être la grande
tragédie notre vie abondamment donc dès
l'enfance le très consciente de ton sexe
et p o et des limites que tu dois
attendre ou surtout pas dépenser légaux
j'ai l'impression que c'est pour quelque
chose qui vous traversent souvent les
esprits à moins que je me trompe ben ça
dépend si les images qu'on se fait m je
veux dire oui c'était mon point de 10
les corps on sent pas qu'on a besoin de
foot et dans un moule puis par les
représentations qu'on a de l'homme
depuis dans la dans la culture sont
limoux on a pas de héros qui est grosse
et qui on a des doors clowns et des brad
pitt qui sont nos non standard david
beckham qui font des photos de leonardo
dicaprio et sa plage même si oui mais il
ya leonardo dicaprio
il fait tout les stars nord la beauté
car maymou ses fils orbite jeudi un beat
pour un rôle puis le film d'après ya
plus de billets code pin
c'est l'image tu le verras pas s'aimer
ton il prendra pas de photo shoot avec
son bide son date baudelot non mais
c'est avec une photo de paparazzi
maintes reprises sur une plage où est ce
que lui veut pas se montrer
il n'empêche que une fille qui mettons
qui avec un ebitda plage on va plus nous
parler un peu plus tôt fait critiquer
que je me trouvais cricket ensemble mais
maintenant je crois que c'est un sujet
que j'ai d'abord lu beaucoup avec mes
garçons sexy des fois est ce que vous
avez envie de vous sentir sexy est ce
que des fois vous prenez une photo en
faisant le mode sexy disposait
négativement je trouve que c'est
important d'être connecté avec tronçon
son charme et sa sensualité
j'ai l'impression que les hommes hétéros
c'est pas quelque chose qui est très
encouragé chez vous et je me demande
souvent pourquoi le titre sexy manqué je
sais pas pour le terme sexy mais c'est
sûr que mettons les photos que je vais
publier je les choisis puis allez y en a
que je m'aime plus sur une colonne
piloter mais après ce sexy estimait-on
de vouloir mettre de l'avant ma
sensualité ma sexualité mousse pozzo que
j'explore m'attends maintenant un mot
non plus le cas mais aussi culturel mais
ce que tu l'exploit réussi c'était pas
culturelle c'est une bonne question est
ce que c'est quelque chose qui que
j'aurais envie de force y mettons je me
ferais pas écrire par mes amis gays et à
l'heure de jeu y est ce que c'est
quelque chose que je ferais je ne suis
pas pauvre
pour moi c'est un peu l'équivalent des
photos boudoir des femmes
j'ai fait pour un projet documentaire le
cover du sommet il ya plein de photos de
moi sous vêtements dedans si le nombre
de filles qui m'ont écrit à moi ce
serait mon rêve pas pour ce membre juste
de voir de quoi je pourrais avoir l'air
dans les yeux d'un ou d'une photographe
dans une zone plus intimes vient
toujours répondu c'est marrant il faut
trouver un ou une photographe de
confiance qui laisse toi aller c'était
quelque chose quitte entre temps envie
d'explorer cette sensualité la
préhistoire peu et pas un homme qui
marie christine genêt pourquoi un homme
aurait pas envie d'aller voir dans cette
pâle
c'est sûr que c'est sûr que c'est une
fabrication d'é mettons maintenant on
comprend la pornographie il par exemple
le le gosse sensible est en position de
soumission sont venus s'y incline
croquis mais si on considère ça comme un
king catégorie ultra de neige de comme
feu c'est ultra naish le west que le
guerrier comme des genres c'est pas lui
qui lit des fêtes j'imagine que tout ça
c'est juste une construction si on avait
plus de plus de sensualité chez l'homme
c'est sûr que c'est sûr qu'on serait
plus portés à samatan moi tu me dis
faire des photos boudoir de moins c'est
vraiment pas quelque chose que je
frétille
pourquoi est ce que je le ferai pas je
vais réfléchir à ceux plus en plus de
voir la masculinité
ça passe aussi par et vous donner le
droit à des ondes très très caché je
crois c'est désolant qu'on associe aux
femmes
pour le meilleur ou pour le pire le mois
cette obsession la de la sensualité
j'aurais préféré qu'on me la met pas ses
épaules enfin le je trouve que c'était
c'est démesuré c'est une injonction star
fois c'est l'eau mais il ya un moment où
en tant que qu'adulte j'ai décidé et
systèmes temps d'explorer ça je trouve
ça le fun chose une partie non identité
puis concernant ce qui plonge la daps
téléphone mais quand j'en ai parlé à
chacun de mes partenaires ou même amigos
que des points d'interrogation et je ne
sais pas c'est quoi ma fille ma
sensualité d'homme je trouve pas ça je
pense pas que je trouve pas ça normal
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est une
injustice en fait
exprime exactement ma passe en ce moment
métier dit mettons le corps de la femme
était dans la société je parle beaucoup
plu aux petits filippi sexualisé que le
cas de la pythie mettons ça a été muté m
pour vendre des produits pour vendre des
avant tout
puis après sortie même si même si après
ce par choix d'une femme décide
d'arrêter de revendiquer sa sexualité
fidèles dans ces zones là parfois le
résultat c'est quand même les mêmes
codes qu'ils aiment la mer c'est du
point de vue de celui qui regarde ce
cela même si les mêmes genres d'imagerie
comment ce que je te dis je comprends
que mon ticket que c'est quand même
vraiment mieux qui aimait tant que
l'état soit les femmes qui allaient
pouvoir là dessus plutôt qu'une
industrie des hommes en gris qui qui
m'était possible ça me fait passer
mettons à caen libye exemple c'est sa
nouvelle toune t web
s'ils sont les clefs pts et si hilarant
si l'arast c'est drôle de sa vie
sexuelle mais oui pitié je comprends que
je suis un million de fois mieux que
elle revendique eu cette qualité puis
elle soit m dsk veut présent l'éclair
est vraiment pouvoir dire s'il se trouve
que c'est du point de vue de la personne
qui regarde ses potes regard métier
mettons à vendre l'équipe d'europe
c'était le rappeur entouré de filles
puis ce rapport le home bénéficier la
sexualisation des femmes à son avantage
pilot clk bénéficie offre que c'est
mieux mais c'est andré encore l'âme en
imagerie pis vouloir sortir du code moi
c'est ça aussi la mort je veux dire
mettons et moi mais il ya des moments où
je me trouve très sexy parce que je
dessine maintenant de me laisser pousser
un peu de poil entrée libre
moi des fois il ya des fermes le que je
trouve terme ans ex qui ont annoncé des
profits je me suis dit tant que moi je
me trouverai ce texte laissait le jeu
ben ouais ok oui je peux le trouver mais
ton et sexy en dehors du code mais quand
je mets de la lingerie
par le normatif qui répond tout à fait
aux codes je peux le sentir extrêmement
sexy aussi ont été revendiqués s'est pas
vouloir non plus refaire le mot le
sapeur vouloir être ça pour être
correspond exactement à ce que la
société attend toi tu es tout et pour
tout et pour rébellion dans le fait de
revendiquer sa sexualité sic en débit
est trop sexy avec ses seins comme des
missiles dans un soufflé au port entouré
de félins bango fois ritz évasif et même
si ça correspond à ce que la société
veut et d'autres gares sophie dit m
c'est vraiment un beau cette manne
féministe un petit peu dégradant pour la
fin d'année
moi je trouve que c'est merveilleux moi
ça c'est moi ça me fait rire ça fait
partie d'une je voudrais les paroles de
web sont hilarantes quelqu'un qui
s'arrête au premier degré même le jeu
l'amener à comprendre pourquoi quelqu'un
serait fâché contre une fille qui jouit
au point qu'on doivent remplir des
chaudières le jeudi 6 ans atteint sur
maps et se situe ripon un peu en
entendant une femme proposer un gars de
passer son nid dans sa vulve comme une
carte de crise on n'a pas le même sens
de l'humour fin et chaque mois cette
chanson me fait rire puis après ça je
vois le vidéoclip qui reprend des
clichés vu mille fois mais par des yeux
d'hommes dans des oeufs de femmes
choisies amuse toi et je vois rien de
dégradant là dedans mais je pense que
pour faire changer la perception de la
femme comme à être non sexuée ben y'a
personne de murs que car débit et je me
projette en tofu on pense de temps que
la femme ne veut pas des textes
donc il faut la chasse et puis la
convaincre mais quand des biches
participants que nous envoie
l'impression qu'il faut la chasse et la
campagne nous envoie le message que l'on
veut qu'elle en veut plus et que tu le
fais pas tout à fait correct a dit
merckx et féministe moi j'ai aucun
problème avec ça maintenant si c'était
le style disco féminin qu'on entendait
mais oui je trouverais se refermer la
vérité c'est qu'il en existe une
pluralité
le cas type de famille n'est ce pas
exagéré
[Rires]
c'était le cas face aux mensualités de
la sexualité puis le discours de corps
débit est aussi légitime qui est celui
d'une femme qui trouve qu'à votre au
loin parce que pourrait elle est là la
sensualité c'est quelque chose de
mystique et de spirituel je voudrais
tout le monde a droit de s'exprimer dans
sa relation détruire puis dans l'idée de
revendiquer ta propre sensualité il ya
aussi un peu le une des raisons qui
m'avaient loin des frais à ceux c'est
justement que au delà de décode que toi
tu connais envers toi même c'est que tu
sais que les personnes qui peuvent
intéresser vont être aussi e régis par
des codes
qu'est ce qui peut les attirer avec en
prenant mes temps comme tu dis si toi tu
te sens sexy en anglais sans pousser le
poil c'est malgré tout un risque que tu
prends que la personne qui est de
l'autre côté qui pourrait intéresser et
régis par les codes l'appui elle trouve
pas sûr parce qu'elle n'a pas réussi à
briser squad le sam enquête mais ça
reste encore dans sa psyché peas et
c'est une ligne qui espère d'ici là
négocier parce que pas grand monde sa
mais pas super fan de poids celui de
combat ok on est un petit peu je ne
toucherai pas autant que tu es dans ta
face de taiwan trop sexy avec un titre
repose selon les essais mais on en
discute puis je pense que on peut pas
forcer à désirer sur autrui on peut pas
marcher non plus un travail de
déconstruction sociale et 24 heures sur
je pense que c'est vraiment question de
respecter les libertés puis les
préférences aussi d'autres 8 ici parce
que je veux dire on a beau se libérer de
tout carcan je pense qu ultime ans il va
rester des préférences et sexuelle qui
et qui m'appartiennent pas j'ai des amis
qui sont allés beaucoup plus loin dans
ses tests loeb qui sont pas rasé mettons
pendant deux ans puis qui ont eu des
conversations difficiles avec des
prétendants le sens commun moi ça
m'intéresse pas
ok ça backfire multi moment elles se
sont respectés dans leur désir de voir
où ça allait les mener
puis je trouve que ça en dit long là
encore c'est peut-être certains
mécanismes de défense aussi mais moi il
ya quelque chose que je trouve beau et
de m'afficher très rapidement et dans
qui je suis et mentalement comme
corporellement puis de voir comment
l'autre personne réagi parce que sam en
dit beaucoup sur elle c'est quand mon
coeur me dit pas moi je serai pas sur le
poil mais vos efforts ça montre que je
les choisis pour une bonne raison aux
morts tous à 100 ce qui est capable de
m'exprimer km qui te respecter
exactement et mes envies aussi puis
comprend discuter mais tandis que si
rapidement il m'avait dit mais moi ça
m'écoeure un poil ben je pense que ça va
envoyer un autre signal de fermeture
essayez des affaires je trouve que c'est
pour le mieux
puis après ça c'est à l'autre d accepter
ou peu mais à mon avis le corps de
chaque personne lui appartient pour de
vrai tous et nike libre d'essayer des
enfants de de refuser le cas comment qui
dans sa forme normale naturelle c'est
quand même spécial comme ce pas ça c'est
vraiment spécial
surtout qu'on en dise pour beaucoup
c'est aux hommes j'allais dire 0 le
mexique quel genre d'altération on vous
demande vraiment le socialement de
manière massive
j'ai plus de difficulté à voir du cargo
mettons ces paires et le tx est ou non
si vraiment ces décisions là il ya une
pression sociale pour le faire ou ou
contre le dc non g dames sarah voir ce
qu'on vous demande très rapidement alors
kate et moi ma mère m'a appris à me
raser jambes et j'avais 12 ans le
j'avais 12 ans c'est fou mais on va
quand même mon sens on sent qu'on est
dans une phase
changement puis de déconstruction c'est
sur la plaine niveau parce que cette
discussion là vu le dise à l'existant
même piste mm pô c'est d'abord d'être
vraiment réalisées radical une vie avec
du poil c'était beau mais on l'accepté
et beaucoup grâce au jeune influence us
très bien on commence à le voir en fait
il est super intéressant qui s'appelle
j'oublie mais c'est une c'est un recueil
de tout plein de photos qui ont été
censurés sur instagram est donc c'est un
travail collectif le les gens voyaient
la photo voici pourquoi je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai été censuré
le tu réalises très rapidement que ce
sont des corps qui ne sont pas blancs en
grande majorité qui naquit ne
contrevient pas aux règles d'instagram
n'y a pas de nudité souvent ayez du poil
qui sort d'un maillot de bain ou d'une
culotte ou stress maillot du poil sur
une peau qui plus foncée et que blanche
et donc même si ça contrevient pas aux
règles
c'est censuré donc en ce moment aux
dires des voix on en voit de plus en
plus de poils sur instagram le poil
convoi yves blanc ils sont des jeunes
femmes
il est souvent teint pour iphone qui dit
accompagné d'un corps qui correspond à
100% standards de beauté blonde dit
inquiet ça devient de plus en plus
mainstream mais après ça une femme qui
serait par exemple grosse et qui serait
de couleur qui serait lesbienne donc le
notre lecture serait complètement
différent il montrait plus tendance ou
sera-t-elle revendique son poil on
serait beaucoup plus dans les clichés le
con qu'on y met rapidement puis même si
c'est qu'on réussit à les voir parce que
je rappelle cette agression je lai
censure
donc oui on en discute de plus en plus
mais là encore quand ça vient pas trop
ébranler même justement on parlait
dernièrement de diversité corporelle
tpiy les personnes qui prône la
diversité la diversité corporelle qui
ont une très très large audience c'est
des gens qui se répondent quand même au
temps lors de votre maison
tu verras pas quelqu'un
prenez la diversité corporelle à voir où
tous ses amis la bonne il sait où tu
m'aimes mais souvent il ya beaucoup de
mannequins par exemple tant et plus
c'est qu'ils ont un ventre extrêmement
pleut c'est son nom exact sera encore
beaucoup de difficultés
oui vraiment qui a lâché idéale juste
peut-être sur un autre frein même si on
veut minimiser globalement thé avec une
belle une taille cintrée avec des
hanches des saintes et donc ont encore
bien du travail à faire puis c'est je
pense qu'on a les femmes qui
correspondent pas nécessairement aux
standards de beauté qui osent explorer
leur sensualité puis faire c'est
profiter de leur corps puis l'exposé de
la manière qu'ils l'entendront selon moi
un courage immense qui doivent
probablement faire face à beaucoup plus
de violence que les autres que feu sur
le moyen y compris le sens c'est sûr et
certain
c'est facile pour moi de dire je me
laisse un peu pousser pour voir si c'est
sexy je me ferais pas insulter pour ceux
justement qui concerne québec me
concerne oui je savoir les commentaires
qu'un safia avait sorti son clip de hey
oui ce qui était nulle dans les chaises
exact comme les commentaires c'était
c'était des comme ça c'est complètement
et c'est horrible d'où l'importance des
faits derrière le roaming de project qui
ont accompagné sa fière dans les clips
casse entre 4,0 et sarah unis qui
montrent des femmes et dans toute leur
diversité puis dans la manière aussi
dont elles ont envie d'être représentés
on est tellement habitué de voir la
femme dans le meilleur game dans le
regard de l'homme et donc dans certaines
postures qui cache la cellulite même son
nom à tout qui cache les petits plis qui
qui qui demande la tension qui a envie
d'être qui a envie de séduire qu'on est
complètement le succube pion par leur
part à secondes on voit des femmes vu
par d'autres femmes dans la manière dont
elles l'entendent
puis il y en a encore beaucoup trop peu
de projets comme ce clip le monde
project malheureusement tu vois tu y
mettons en comparatif avec qui les clips
de cons libye même si les deux sont des
initiatives vous y allez quand même un
qui déconstruit plus que l'autre les
codes ces salles on peut pas demander à
tout le monde et construit puis quand il
déconstruit certains codes à sa manière
je suis avide de secours en cas de
l'escaut vraiment de com du rapport que
que sais-je à toutes les bêtises qui ça
tousse moitié elle c'est comme un
manteau dépasser pour y jette pas assez
bon vous n'êtes pas assez pour
déconstruire un code puis je pense que
de toute façon pluralité tactique
validée de discours puis toute
initiative venant d'une personne qui a
envie de s'affirmer
puis de montrer qui elle est tout en
respectant les lois qu'il entend
doit-être salué au nom mais là tu vois
tu je fais pratiquement la vie quotidien
parce que tu es moi je trouve ça le fun
je trouve ça pour ça drôle je trouve ça
beau le 10 mai mais j'étais riche km
contre les féministes est ce que tu
m'aimais pour venir au poil je trouve ça
motive que tu disais si les chances
qu'une femme se fasse insulter ça m'a
rappelé une histoire du secondaire qui
complètement décalé sensée que si moi je
me suis mannequin qu'on réfléchisse fort
il y en a mais je me souviens très bien
d'une histoire d'une faillite il y avait
une expérience sexuelle avec un goût à
la vie du poêle puis le genre il est
fait à ce titre le dit à tout le monde
c'est dégueulasse un appui genre à
l'école c'était comme elle a assisté
comme la grosse affaire
à quel point tct gêne c'est un des
premiers à quel point c c c c difficile
pire décrotter à tabanac face les
phoques tome de s'attendre à ce que tout
le monde sera aux jeux devraient
globalement pour le choix les travaux
qu'on puisse attendre alpes et tantôt de
sa tante ça me regarde épaules mais que
toute une école secondaire sans borne
et puis je m'inclus là dans le mouvement
rappelle justement demandé en seconde ou
des poêlons si je disposais de tout
raser qu'est-ce que je suppose et rasé
puis toutes les amies filles on en
discute ensemble pour avoir une
stratégie c'était tellement important
pour nous de faire la bonne affaire
dix ans brise le coeur chez pas à 15 ans
le taux tellement d'autres laissant
supposer que je supposais me raser juste
les lèvres ou le pubis aussi c'est
incroyable l'énergie qu'on a pu mettre
là dessus pour plaire à qui ont des
petits gars qui jouent au football crise
inouïe ultime qui a presque à chaque
vague de dénonciations sont mortes ici
une de leur vie et on va sortir et c'est
pour eux que je me demandais vraiment il
fallait que je me rase intégral calice
mais c'est ça m'aurait puis à quel point
est ce que ta première expérience à quel
point c'est une pression folle top c'est
parce que c'est mettons cette histoire
le j'en ai facilement de on en a parlé
dernièrement qui me reviennent en tête
qui sont la même chose
c'est une expérience sexuelle qui se
passe le gars qui le dit à tout le monde
tout le monde est au courant que cette
fille là et y sept filets fait x 1 puis
le tout le monde le sait mais à quel
point c'est une scène que cette pression
là soit mise alors que c'est déjà un
moment stressant complètement debost
mais tellement dévoué de l'éducation
sexuelle ou très très triste et très
pauvres mais pas de condom tu vas mourir
on n'est pas des gens formés pour faire
ce qui était juste ma récente et puis
non c'est ceci claque dont nous parlait
beaucoup de points communs dans la
semaine c'est une aberration qu'il faut
qui absolument changer oui parce que je
veux dire
moi je pense qu'une grande part de ce
qu'on a vécu venait du fait qu'on
discutait pas grandement mon cours
d'éducation sexuelle on appelle une prof
de français nous a appris qu à coucher
c'est comme sortir une orange les
narines
puis je pense que si j'ai pas d'enfant
c'est probablement pour sulaco marié
losique une narine c'est comme une
petite information
mais cet illustre et cela ne s'arrange
rentable mais c'est si on avait des
cours d'éducation sexuelle qui ont du
bon sens mais peut-être que les jeunes
garçons penserai peut qu est un pré
requis
et puis c'est très hétéro normatif
comment je parle le mais j'ai
l'impression que les femmes les filles
ça sent moins après l'autre fille soit
rasé je pense la majorité où l'on parle
désolé pour mon langage de tout mettre
sur le dos des hommes encore mais je
pense question dans toutes les gares et
trains de s'attendre au modèle unique
pour nous aussi la génération pour nous
le monde c'était ça mon éducation
sexuelle puis c'est une maman
déconstruire éducation ben s'écrie c'est
la moins bonne représentation de la
vraie vie qui existe c'est que sa
performance là encore plutôt que la
communication pitt et je sais pas pour
vous mais nous on fait on parle beaucoup
de sexe je pense probablement plus que
jamais un pape au dessus enfin on va
quand même loin dans l'intimité pied
autre que moi avec beaucoup d'amis de
filles on se moque souvent le des
performances pour nous le temps quand il
y en a un amant qui regardais trop de
porno on le sait en tabarouette parce
que ça vient avec un décorum
ascom et encaissa gueule le lui ces
codes c'est vraiment vraiment pillon ça
se pourrait qu'on en parle après puis de
manière respectueuse
mais l'amant pour nous c'est quelque
chose qu'on connaît et qu'on dénonce
entre nous des choses qui existent oui
c'est la séquence cia voulu reproduire
une vidéo
mais ce que ça dit la main pour nom
c'est que on parle ici damman qui se
compteraient crise de leurs partenaires
donc qui ne sont pas à l'écouté sur la
performance directement plutôt qu'elle a
de quoi on pourrait juste qu'on pressent
dans son pot temps de quoi te
nécessairement toi envie chatons service
met you ainsi une opportunité
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ouais mais qui
reproduisent une res théâtre vu mille
fois sans même être dans leur corps
probablement ce qui est triste pour
l'amant pour noël
il essaye de reproduire quelque chose
plutôt que de vivre une expérience si on
sait qu'il ya c'est vraiment la première
fois qu'on n'a pas ce terme là mais on
dirait que c'est on dirait que ça ça
symbolise tellement bien l'idée que
l'idée que je me fais de la
problématique oui puis c'est que c'est
que sa part pas dans une mauvaise passe
le l'amant porno il pense sûrement que
la personne avec qui couche il trouve du
plaisir parce que d'abord nous convient
de maintenir à kiev et si jamais fait ça
m'apparaît toujours le bien exactement
mais donc cette personne ne pense
sûrement qu est ce qui fait qu aurait dû
ou encore le manque de communication
c'est triste et mais on a pensé offrir
rapidement à ne pas froisser l'ego d'un
partenaire paquet est souvenu oui oui
moi quand souvent non et un témoin a été
une discussion gestion avec mes amis
c'est aussi le jour on s'est dit bon ben
ce terminus au fait qui s'est terminée
répondent oui à est revenu quand tu es
prévenu personne devra être fâché de se
la personne n'était pas obligé d'être
venu non plus la personne peut faire
comme baisse que c'est quelque chose qui
t'intéresse cette idée là cette idée le
jeu persuadé que le discours que tu que
tu en es tu vraiment je suis persuadé
que ça mind phoque crissement des gueux
et oui pipi moi le premier et oui bon dj
banon mais personne qui a fait qu'il ait
maigri de fimela les pourcentages de
chansons calotte les pauses lipoly
pourcentage de chances sont quasiment
100% que ce soit eux soit arrivée dans
ta vie que la feuillade a menti sur son
plaisir cette fois là pour te faire
plaisir
c'est pourquoi ce sur des pertes parce
qu'on se fait tellement dit que ce
serait la fin c'est quand est survenu
non mais pour mathieu la prochaine fois
besoin de vous il faut qu'on continue
qu'on fasse de caractère
areva se donne un coup de main c'est
quelque chose qui t'intéresse su
parfaitement et comment sa tante
on sait tout comment venir en jeu mais
pas tous mais on est nombreux à savoir
comment jouer
informez-vous la guerre on a deux trois
quatre cinq
ça va être réglé en général qui promet
et puis ça se discute aussi mais cette
idée lors que qui s'est terminée parce
que le gars est venu puis quand il va me
demander si moi aussi je veux y
répondent oui pour pas eu peur de perdre
c'est une conséquence et un conseil
c'est quelque chose qu'on apprend très
très jeune qui prend un temps de
construire puis quand tu commences à
faire trop lisse qu'il y avait une
personne qui fâchent et de peu d'avoir
fait jouer paris hippiques et ça discute
mais c'est fou et je pense j'ai perdu
deux belles grandes occasions en pensant
que je devais m'en tire sur mon plaisir
pour faire plaisir à quelqu'un le nombre
d'orgasmes qu'il est exactement
pu dire non j'ai pas juif rarement que
la majorité des personnes avec qui
servit aurait fait comme acquis que
c'est sans doute arriver j'aurais
vraiment aimé ce mardi au piton ensemble
work it out
mais socialement on se fait dire que il
faut faire attention sentiment des gars
font partie visiblement l'homme
trouverait sa fierté dans la sexualité
ça aussi c'est super problématique c'est
d'assumer que legault il veut toujours
piqué l'orgueil c'est important pour lui
que son partenaire ou sa partenaire elle
jouit l'encore et on peux-tu
déconstruire ce est ce qu'on peut voir
la sexualité en dehors du spectre de
l'orgasme
c'est tout ça est à refaire j'étais
beaucoup de lyonnais des gueules qui
vont qui vont aller chercher leurs
valorisations justement leur confiance
quasiment avec le nombre de partenaires
qui ont un hippie à quel point ce sont
10 sur 10 le tpiy ceci non métier puis
conduire là dedans quand même que tu as
besoin de 10 e tu as besoin d elle à la
théâtrale vous luxe avec moi que c'est
ce qui donne un boost d'ego c'est quand
même moment spécial mais moi ça me fait
de la peine que quelqu'un trouve de
l'intérêt en ma personne mais ton pour
se booster de lego c'est j'aurais envie
de croire que si tu partages quelque
chose d'aussi intime que la sexualité
avec quelqu'un c'est parce qu'elle est
dans nos envies pour des bonnes raisons
ces entrées que ce que je trouve très
sérieusement la posture de la personne
qui a été utile c'est quelque chose de
tellement pauvres dans le cercle de te
l'entendre se disait c'est humain et
j'ai lu et la trajectoire des confettis
et c'est vraiment excellent passage ça
c'est vraiment une plongée dans la
sexualité puis tout ce qui l'entouré
motive mans pyschologiquement puis on
arrive enfin une entrevue la semaine
passée en france parce que son livre ça
ressort le puis j'ai juste vu une
situation qui m'a tellement marqué
et on a par da sexualité parce que la
sexualité c'est le chaos
une personne va vivre le chaos
puis je me suis dit waouh je pense que
tout est là la sexualité c'est le chaos
c'est la rencontre avec quelqu'un que tu
sais pas comment ça va se passer que tu
sais pas les répercussions que ça va
ravoir remotive mans sur toi
physiquement c'est une plongée dans le
vide
même si pas la première fois chaque
relation sexuelle et tu sais pas où ça
s'en veut
c'est chaotique et le chaos fait peur
donc on reproduit les mêmes modèles pour
pas trop effrayer ou avoir l'impression
qu'on contrôle ce magnifique kaul c'est
bien du coup mais s'est inspiré de
maillard mais non mais c'est une
réflexion qui crissent main importante à
avoir en tant que société puis quand
même commencé à être une militante en
2020 en ce moment avec toutes ces
questions de moosch ne considère pas
comme nécessairement militant pour pour
rien dit je pense que je parle du
véganisme et et puis c'est peut-être ce
moment mon cheval de guerre oui puis
mais en ce moment c'est vraiment pas ce
qui remet en question tout le temps ça
me demande pas d'énergie pis pour toutes
ces questions là qu'on se pose depuis le
début tout ce qui est vague de
dénonciations tout ce qui est justice
sociale je me considère pas comme
militant pour ces choses là je suis
juste épuisé des jeux depuis le début de
l'année commencé parce que toutes ces
questions qu'on se pose depuis tantôt
sont remis de l'avançon basculer son
sont percutés ils s'entrechoquent il ddd
histoire que tu lis qu'ils sont
terrifiantes qui est des affaires sur le
consentement kitty 6 on décolle quand il
ya des des gens qui se font tirer dans
l'eau partout dans le monde sait comment
comment ça va moins ça va
puis parlant des fusillades et moi en ce
moment je pourrai jamais considérer que
c'est une militante anti raciste peintes
trop de chemin et trop d'éducation à
acquérir est lui dans la l'éducation
vraiment et la contemplation forking
horrifié en me demandant ce que je peux
faire puisque je peux faire ça commence
par revoir mes propres préjugés
comportement fac je peux pas me
prononcer là dessus je n'ai que de
respect pour les militants dans ce
moment qui sont au front pour une
situation qui est urgente
puis importante l'intimité se lit aussi
je peux faire une hiérarchie le méchant
je pourrai jamais me fatigue assez
faible en ce moment là jamais je n'ai
pas le droit de dire ce qu'on vous
demande d'aider des personnes noires qui
voit là vraiment propre communauté se
faire tirer dans rue oui et encore et
encore à qui on affiche c'est trop mal
je voudrais littéralement le sur des
écrans à répétition parce que nous
partageons feignant la surprise c'est
alors que ces personnes ont grandi en
sachant qu'ils puissent partir à tout
moment là je veux dire c'est jeu en ce
moment ce sont mes plus grande source
d'admiration pis malgré tout ce qui se
passe au rayon de l'intimité où je me
considère militante et en ce moment
c'est elle qui ont besoin de notre
secours puis pas de notre recours dans
ce sens qu'on veut les sauver mais plus
d'un filet le faucon les ensembles ont
peuplé les s'écrier dans le vide
ça suffit ayons besoin de nos oreilles
de nos actions ils ont besoin qu'on
revoit nos sillons besoin qu'on compte à
ce constat pour faire de la place aux
gens qui la méritent beaucoup plus que
nous ayons besoin qu'on partage le micro
ce que je voudrais c'est ce que je
voulais dire par le mauvais choix de
modèles secours et parallèlement il ya
tout ce qui se passe du côté intime où
j'étais entre et le cynisme de couleurs
messines en 2 ans pièces art pas avancé
de toute façon j'en viendrais crier dans
tous les micros hockey
une femme ça se respecte que le
consentement c'est sexy puis arrêtez de
violer et je sais en dessous puis entre
eybens le ya des trains qui tombent ans
d'existence avait des gens je pense
avoir peur pour vous parce que on dirait
qu'il ya des conséquences qui commence à
être appliquée donc ça dépend du jour le
aujourd'hui bonnes moeurs et je serai
comme détail tonnes
il ya des choses avancent il ya de plus
en plus de boys club qu'on est en train
de dénouer j'entends des gens changer de
position que je crois sincère et jean
beaucoup de garçons dans mon entourage
ces questions pour le comportement des
femmes aussi mais ce chiffre est déjà
plus habitués que des femmes se remettre
en question le désordre et je voyage je
vois une volonté maintenant est encore
est très centré sur les gens qui ont
déjà le pouvoir dans le sens qui est ok
moi je veux parler de dénonciation des
femmes autochtones alors qu'elles sont
hautement plutôt chic des femmes
blanches mais j'en ai pas entendu
beaucoup de médias parler de cet enjeu
le fac et pour moi ça met en lumière
toutes les injustices intersectionnelle
dont on parle peu mais quand j'ai des
duty zélande et sports de yodé
conséquence jean revient quand même à me
dire mais et qu'on rit le ben oui
vraiment donc très moi je peux en parler
un peu de problèmes puis je recevrai pas
de messages négatifs parce que j'ai
parlé de te met sa finale on va en
parler puis finalement réalise tout le
monde motors
pourquoi parce que ça correspond pas à
ce que la société attend d'une femme
alors que moi oui donc il ya un jour son
dojo optimiste mais je reste fort king
cynique mars que les jo à ce que tu sais
exactement ce qu il reste tellement à
faire puis parce que il ya toujours le
dilemme des ce que je le prend le micro
ou je le prends pour aider je vous en
parlais dans quel point cette année où
je les espoirs qu'on voit inviter
quelqu'un d'autre à ma place qui le
méritent plus après ça comment je
partage le micro davantage pis
je peux tu dire à n'importe quelle
équipe médiatique très tôt tu pensé à
inviter quelqu'un qui est plus touché
statistiquement les femmes autochtones
sont bien plus pourquoi ta personne
d'autochtones sur ton panel c'est mon
rôle c'est le rôle acquis c'est
certainement un peu mon rôle en mettant
ce moment la productrice du show
bref c'est comme ça que je me sens et
comme lors de tourisme en a construit il
ya un espèce de sentiment des devoirs
mais je sais pas encore comment
l'exécuter ou comment cette discipline
comme on sait quelle est ta place dans
ce c'est compliqué kamal kamal kamal la
prendre comme à l'aller c'est exactement
c'est maintenant quand je fais des
discussions où on invite plusieurs
personnes soit sur le féminisme
maintenant je le montre le temps qu'ils
qu'est le puis je m'assurer parce que je
participe à un panel qui est diversifiée
mais en même temps je la limite de
contrôle kg qui dort doit parler
je prends par la place à ceux pour qui
la donne à personne
probablement un homme féministe en fait
c'est quand ces oies noires ces supports
le que c'est moi où un homme féministe
fait que je préfère le prendre
j ai pu dans les panels maintenant quand
je monte qui va avec la cdg diversifié
pissant sent qu'il ya un plus grand
réflexe mais il ya quand même des zones
où on veut papier par exemple les femmes
autochtones pour moi c'est un angle mort
immense dans les médias on ne veulent
pas en parler même si statistiquement
elles sont les plus touchés pourquoi tu
ris parce qu'on s'en fout plus parce que
c'est moins important taux d'émission
ses toilettes en dessous du tapis depuis
trop longtemps
c'est la plus grande aberration celi
femmes autochtones et les peuples
autochtones
historiquement au québec au canada c'est
je prends des hiérarchies métis il y
plus de prix mais aussi
ça c'est le plus grand c'est la grosse
tache notre histoire puisque autant on
parle de l'importance des cours
d'éducation à la sexualité
oui bien sûr mais nos cours d'histoire
et moi ce que j'ai appris sur les
peuples autochtones et les maisons
l'ongle puis on m'a jamais parlé de
pensionnat on ne peut parler de génocide
certainement pas et des gens qui sont
pas encore capables de nommer le mot et
tous ceux et est à revoir aussi avant un
cours d'éducation à la sexualité je
voudrais pour un cours d'histoire qui
est obligée de choisir mais dans les
médias tous ces besoins doivent être
reflétés autant je trouve qu'on n'entend
pas céder sexologue ni de discussions
franches sur la sexualité autant je
trouve qu'on a des idées complètement de
culte et une part des citoyens canadiens
même dans les enjeux qui les touchent
les plus comme les dénonciations d'abus
sexuels sur north humanité et sa galaxie
aux votes cast et pillent tellement de
dossiers tellement de réalité à laquelle
j'avais jamais entendu parler mais
depuis j'ai petit j'ai comme on dit mais
la crise d'oka c'est comme flousta
courage pendant qu'à vienne qu'il est et
comme crif sur les familles recherchent
puis le wikipedia pis tabarnak tout ça
pour un choriste de terrain de golf si
tu te rends compte à quel point ça n'a
aucun sens et c'est super complexe qui
sait aussi que je pense que c'est
souvent abordé sous un même prisme dans
les médias par exemple moi j'aime
beaucoup le travail de christopher
curtis un journaliste anglo qui couvre
beaucoup les enjeux autochtones avec une
approche je dirai pas plus mais c'est
pas le bon mot mais maintenant plus
terrain où il donne la parole aux
principaux concernés et où tu découvres
un enjeu plus souvent sur leur corps que
sous le regard supposément objectif
aujourd'hui c'est dit et moi je crois au
journalisme les journalistes on met
personne préféré je veux dire que je
peux dire qu'il faut pas les croire faut
toujours les croire à mon avis mais il
ya un an glide analyse qui souvent
privilégié où on est un peu au dessus de
l'ange heures pour essayer de le rendre
de manière le plus objectif la manière
la plus objective possible
moi j'aime bien quand on donne aussi le
la parole à une communauté en acceptant
le biais lutter jugement je vais aller
me m'intéresser à la communauté
autochtone je suis le tendre le micro
puis le fip je trouve ça super
intéressant parce que j'apprends
beaucoup et sur des enjeux qui sont
souvent vraiment est mis sous le tapis
mais ça j'ai l'impression que que c'est
la cesci brisée dans le journalisme mais
j'ai l'impression
parce que moi j'ai j'ai un problème avec
le avec les nouvelles de qui quoi
comment
combien coûtent ces justes juste des
réponses à des questions des faits s'est
défait ce n'est pourtant en avoir mais
tu perds vraiment l'enjeu réel qui a
tellement d'opinion il ya ce sentiment
de pignons partout moi à ses fans des
nouvelles et c'est vraiment objective le
qui quoi comment met-on je te parle pas
nécessairement d'opinion mais c'est
quelqu'un qui va dans la communauté puis
qui rencontre ces gens-là ce ça permet
d'avoir vraiment une meilleure idée de
réellement c'est crois que juste d'avoir
un chiffre vient juste d'avoir la peau
les médias sont en crise et on punissait
renvoyer une salade dans ta salle de
rédaction ne peut plus avoir un tu peux
pas payer
combien de riom journaliste qui veut qui
écrit d'ailleurs été investi de un esti
3000 mots sont le samedi une fois chaque
mois la chancellière jours pour faire et
puis je pense que tout le monde qui
travaille qui gravitent dans le milieu
rêverie et de la cession de ce
journalisme le mais en même temps on
consomme nouvelle sur facebook de
manière gratuite mais on veut pas payer
quatre pièces pour un abonnement
numérique à la presse au devant de
l'information qu'on mérite rendu le
présent un effort c'est clair non si
c'est effectivement une des grandes
questions à se poser
ça c'est tellement important le
journalisme ccc ce qui nous protège de
tellement de d'abus d'injustice j'y
crois et du plus profond de mon cas j'ai
un respect immense pour les journalistes
puis je vois leurs conditions de travail
je trouve que c'est de notre tristesse
parce qu'on réalise pas à quel point ils
sont essentiels à notre bien-être
collectif dont on ignore complètement
puis en ce moment auprès faire on
je pense que personne autour de la table
mais beaucoup de gens préfèrent et nier
leur existence les dénigrer lé faire
croire les farrelly croire mental tout
ce mouvement le contre les médias
mais bouleverse je ne le comprends pas
il ya des gens très intelligents moi mon
entourage comme il mais tu sais que les
journalistes sont aux tâches t par le
gouvernement jusqu'au souvenir pour la
formation
non je sais pertinemment que les
journalistes ne seront pas payés par
contre est tout sauf sauter pourquoi
d'où sa vie qu après ça comment rétablir
un lien de confiance avec des gens qui
sont mondou tellement loin de la réalité
que tu demandes
est-ce qu'ils sont même réchappant oui
je le sais pas mais en même temps on
peut parler les sacs de plus en plus
nombreux on veut précisément ce qui est
en train de se passer et c'est
terrifiant baisse c'est peut-être ça qui
me fait le plus peur quand le show est
vraiment il
vraiment une montée le extrême des
conspirationnistes fidèles de remettre
en doute toutes les autorités le dit que
ce gouvernement table que ce soit et
puis je avoir un esprit critique pied
douter je sais la base la réflexion mais
après se douter de tout le temps de tout
ce qui est officiel douter de la science
c'est extrêmement dangereux qui mettons
le lot de jolies choses ne soient aurait
plus on se parlait du mouvement quincy
puis j'ai posté koala la base plus je
vais m'informer la subit c'est
extrêmement inquiétant vraiment
dangereux parce qu'ils étaient des
communautés immense de personnes qui
croient des absurdités qui croient des
pit et pour l'instant ça va au métier
mais ces gens-là se mobilisent prennent
les armes parce qu'il parle que le
gouvernement veut le faire un coup
d'état ou quoi que ce soit le second
aurait pu lui c'est super drôle de ça
devient dramatique non moi je pense
qu'on les a fait trop dont les autres
considérés comme gagne minoritaire de
coucou je pense qu'on ne peut réaliser
l'ampleur de ce qui se passe et puis moi
je m'auto tape sur les doigts la tue le
jeu moi je vois de plus en plus de gens
dans mon entourage je prends une twister
et conspirationnistes et puis je sais
que c'est pas des termes qu'ils aiment
ça que je sais que tout autre le mettons
quand même dubitatif de tort puis je me
dis ok lui il ya quelque chose qu'il
faut qu'on fasse des deux bords c'est
moi je crois la science je crois à ce
que au journalisme je crois même en
bonne partie et à la bonne volonté de
notre gouvernement
je suis prête à faire un putsch qui eux
ne croient plus à rien de tout ça
comment on fait pour établir des ponts
parce qu'on peut pas les brûlent ils ont
au début c'est ce qu'on faisait le jeu
mars que les conspirationnistes non ça
fonctionne plus va falloir qu'on
constante la main parce que autrement je
serais pas capable de donner ce soir
plus ce personnage est isolée plus va
s'enfoncer tué puis plus à vos centres
qu'elle a plus en commun avec les gens
avec les communes externe est vraiment
les membres de sa famille puis c'est à
ce moment là qui sont récupérés
beaucoup de gens disent il faut pas en
parler dans les médias puis moi je me
dis mais non parce qu'on va rendre
légitime leur sentiment d'oppression
mais personne ne croit qu'elles sont
censurés même si on m'en parle
abondamment puis que leurs
manifestations sont couverts mais crois
honnêtement qui puisqu'elle détient la
vérité elles sont censurés faux faux
faux faux faux pas rendre illégitime
faut montrer que non non non je prête à
vous entendre je prête à vous marley est
probablement pas prête à céder beaucoup
d'arguments
j'avais mal à l'aise j'arrive à les
inviter quelqu'un ou d'ouvertement
conspirationnistes ici pour avoir un
débat parce que je me suis dit si tu
travailles tu peux pas de batac ces gens
là parce qu'il n'y aura aucun argument
est fluide aux knicks vont nous faire
changer de thème arguments ils vont
questionner la validité des sources pis
quoi que ce soit pour me dire qu'ils
étaient et invendus il ya aucun journal
qui délégitime jamais avoir une
information qui légitime parce que c'est
octopus aux oiseaux sont achetés par
tout ça très beau c'est d'avoir pu
l'apprécier
n'empêche qu'ils apprécient mais tant
que j'aurai pas de 15h30 avec quelqu'un
qui expose six des leurs même si je le
réfute puis pendant ces personnes va
être vraiment plus armées armée contre
arguments donc si j'ai peut-être même
avoir la de perdre le déboutant tension
qui réponds à quelqu'un qui dit que de
toute façon l'état et pedro satanique
qui tique est commentée des baux avec
john key qui sait si c'est ça je pense
que l'objectif entre à mon avis les
médias devraient pas nécessairement être
de tendres plus souvent les micros
directement aux personnes
conspirationnistes mais plus de tendre
le micro à des gens qui réfléchissent à
la radicalisation qui réfléchissent à la
communication et aux relations
interpersonnelles thomas matton script
sur rachida azdouz qui est une
psychologue spécialisée en relations
interpersonnelles puis à l'écrit tout un
livre là-dessus sur comment faire pour
communiquer avec une personne qui s'est
radicalisée sur ses positions sans
couper les ponts sans non plus
monté par escalade et sa conflit puis
c'est tellement importante d'après ans
parce qu'on commence tous leurs avoirs
dans l'eau dans notre famille ce sont
des personnes avec qui on partage pas
les mêmes opinions même que mon moi qui
fonctionne maintenant qu'on va super
qu'hector avant de rentrer jeudi tout
temps qu'est ce qu'on fait si et anti
masque parce que j'essaie public immense
qui est immense qui plus est on en
discute comme acquis mais on dit que
nous on croit à l'importance de ce mets
sont liés aux laiteries gars pas on
n'amène pas la conversation de même si
nous amène là on est faits remontent
nous on croit parce qu'on cherche pas
nécessairement changer de sujet mais on
cherche pas non plus la chicane ok
parfait que l'on veut mais il faut deux
sociétés quand ces mécanismes bleus à
mettre en place
ça m'est arrivé la première fois de me
faire de me faire coller par quelqu'un
qui était intime à ce qu'ils et elles
ont été en tançant obama va salle de
bain fait que je remets mon masque
largement vassal lebrun payer un lieu
qui est là qui se lave les mains ils me
regardent midi devrait pas croiser
quelques gourmandises moment où les
masques l'homme moi je la vis moi j'ai
mon masque
je le regarde plus je dis rien plein
doute et aujourd'hui fait beau dehors le
bras en l'air
je les regardais les fêtes je vais
retourner à ma table
je vais enlever mon masque puis je vais
prendre moi quand je vais être engagée à
ma table c'est parfait puis comme je
suis juste partie mais le gars c'était
la première fois que le challenge est
face à face fille que j'ai quand même
réalisé que auquel t-il espèce de petit
le petit groupe que je semblais voir qui
commençait à prendre de l'ampleur sur
facebook est rendu dans les rangs d'une
étoile avec moi existe pour vrai et
concret exactement puis comment on fait
rendu le pour pas que ça vire en battant
de son fils et à ses gens lequel je
pense qu'on doit donner la parole
davantage moi j'ai besoin en tout cas
comme ou de 6 par rapport à ça parce que
je sais pas et je ne sais pas comment
j'ai ri ça me fait uniquement de la
peine de voir des gens qu'elle gym
duquel je respecte promouvoir des idées
qui vont complètement l'encontre de mes
valeurs et
puis j'ai pas envie de couper les ponts
parce que c'est une solution qui est
certes efficace mais sur le long terme
qui dit rien de bon pour notre
collectivité
le filet social j'ai pas envie
d'abandonner des personnes qui se sont
probablement elle sentie abandonnée par
le système qu'on se rende le fac
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour recoller les
morceaux cassés puis pourquoi le
gouvernement parle peu moins ça serait
mon reproche au gouvernement en ce
moment me faut arrêter de faire semblant
que tout le monde est d'accord il
faudrait qu'ils même site il ya des
chiffres 15 % 15 % c'est trop c'est 15%
de dissidents le pour moi c'est trop
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant pour
avoir une discussion
bah oui c'est ce métier c'est des gens
souvent si c'est si les gens les plus
vulnérables qui vont tomber là-dedans
tpiy 2020 sont extrêmement difficile
pour toi pour tout le monde mais pour
certains plus que dans we tpiy cette
position l'ôter télé jean monty refaite
et recherche et elle cherche à l'ana
sauf que c'est ça vient bien plus de
dignité d'une des préconçues que tu vas
essayer de confirmer à trouver des infos
qui confierait la dès que tu veux déjà
des formes qui fait on à faire plutôt
qu'à vraiment est ce que le masque est
vraiment plus du fait vraiment la
démarche scientifique dé trouver la
réponse à ce parce que si tu le faisais
pour vrai tu arriverais à la réponse est
mais c'est en même temps moi maintenant
la la la pandémie tombe
c gepa de ma maison j'ai pas d'enfant
genre je peux continuer à faire des
podcasts goethe échappé c'est urgent a
rich pas trop stressé bâti mettons j'ai
dit mettons que je pense à une personne
qui me tombe sur mon facebook mais lui
venait s'acheter une maison vient
d'avoir un petit girl huiyan business
qui dans l'événementiel du jour la main
partout j'ai stressé
yves d'érable l'évoquent les chefs
décembre qui est vraiment pas beaucoup
de monde qui sont avec lui par la cave
et faites-lui tipa ci lui dit pas quels
présupposés a fait vivre y prêche pour
sa paroisse le cpie aussi rassurant
d'avoir quelqu'un à blâmer
ouais c'est pas une impression de
contrôle
je pense que je peux aussi me mettais
une impression de contrôle sur une
situation où on en a pas en ce moment
bis est alarmant de pas avoir le moindre
contrôle sur notre vie intime
professionnelle sociale
je ne contrôle plus rien en ce moment le
gouvernement pourra me dire demain ben
et rush et vous obtenez plus de j'aime
puis je ne peux rien faire c'est
horrifiant sage et combler ses besoins
le justement d'appartenance tous les
gens qui font tomber dans des groupes
facebook comme se sent-il isolement
jeudi tout le monde s'est isolé c'est
durant la pandémie
piti leezam ans extrêmement difficile
puis je te marche parce que c'est là
qu'ils trouvent une communauté qui
m'accepte avec qui j'ai des choses en
commun phi phi place apprend plus en
plus par le plus en plus de place il
s'est dit extrêmement ccc les plus
vénérables donc on peut comprendre ces
cheminements doux presque comment on
fait pour se retrouver tout le monde
enfants c'est pour moi y est le lien
manquant je suis capable d'empathie pour
la personne qui tient en trois lettres
mais après ça comment je fais pour
rétablir le contact pour qu'on revienne
dans le même monde
eux ils nous qui le moi je n'ai pas de
solution mais ça commence en france
assez pressants ouais ben oui parce que
s'il faut c'est trop grand tu fais
jamais de bons qu'ils traversent
exactement puis je sais pas qu'ils aient
les compétences pour le faire mais
j'espère que le gouvernement est en mode
de recrutement
j'espère qu'en ce moment ils cherchent
ils qui considère ce dans les infos dans
les trucs impertinent qui est important
à gérer
j'espère parce que dans la gestion de la
règle une deuxième vague il s'en est
cette solidarité sociale je vous demande
en tabarouette comment ça se passe
maintenant martin crise
c'est sur ces points ramène le des du
confinement laitiers
comme on l'a connu l'été on referme les
business tout or ferme ramène cette idée
le pit des émeutes dans les rues de feu
dans le centre ville c'est sûr les gens
sont tannés c'est sûr puis souvent aussi
jeu sans faire de généralisation des
légendes tombant sur ce genre de
personnes qui peuvent faire quand c'est
des affaires et cécile amar de repos et
beaucoup de gens c'est qu'ils font et de
sa part d'une bonne place qui qu'ils
font parce qu'ils y ont vu leurs enfants
et à être complètement déprimé loin de
l'école piquer des impôts de bons simple
vous n'allez pas nous refaire ce
l'impression que beaucoup de souffrance
là dedans en même temps comment tu fais
pour y at il suffisamment d'endroits où
les gens peuvent exprimer leur
souffrance au jeune papa simon attendre
pour voir un psy au public t sa mère
cette pandémie le finalement et il
espèce de révolte qui en résultent chez
une certaine catégorie de personnes met
en lumière un paquet de problèmes
sociaux qu'on ne joue pas exactement
d'après moi il ya des cas la dengue sont
relatifs à la santé mentale et par
rapport à langoat notamment à l'anxiété
et à l'isolément donc qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire globalement pour redonner un chili
au québec oeil
tu es l'exemple mettons les chercher
celle des ce qui se passait chez elle
dessine un microcosme mais quelque chose
de plus gros le prix lustré site un
système qui est déjà qui est déjà
couvert de stress pilule trop tendu le
aa pu être capable de tirer plus la
corde
si tu rajoutes ainsi dresse là dessus en
plus c'est l'autre tout saute c'est un
système qui est déjà plein de défauts
puis que tu es quelqu'un qui sans mari
parle par le système déjà d'entrée de
jeu clôture ajoute en plus l'espèce de
sentiments être contrôlé de plus
personne qui t'a puis tout laisse tomber
mais c'est sûr que c'est le tonnerre
vernement qui a été élu en promettant la
révolution des préposés aux
bénéficiaires à moi c'est un outil qui
l'avaient suivi de près parce que ma
soeur à l'époque était préposé aux
bénéficiaires est épuisé comme tous ses
collègues
on nous promettait la que c'était la fin
une heure piqué et on allait avoir des
heures normales pire meilleurs salaires
et plus de gens ch et celle des c'était
au moment de l'élection qui a récemment
connu françois de quoi être surpris de
ce qui se passait dans les chu celles
déjà bien faire chez épi pour la
situation on en a discuté dans une pige
rien de nouveau là-dedans mais on on a
quand même repoussé des problèmes qu au
bout c'est repoussé la pandémie nous
oblige à prendre action dont les ch et
celle des est ce que ça pourrait faire
la même chose dans les ressources en
aide psychosociale
si tu vois je le jure j'ai eu un échange
entre catherine fourni puis le premier
ministre je te mentirais la jeune homme
habitait sa lumière le terreau nesirky
il ya vraiment une montée de la pensée
complotistes en ce moment au québec
quatre sujets grâce à gauche mais le thé
à la rue avec des chiffres qui étaient
puis vraiment des données là dessus des
résultats d'études sur qui est comme la
montée du conspirationnisme qui lui
répond il répond aux chiffres par une
anecdote et qu'on écoute moi quand je me
promène plus parler aux gens les gens
sont vraiment trop ma défaite arrive
avec des chiffres tu me réponds par ton
expérience personnelle quand il parle on
les gens sont contents d'être là masques
sont pas mal m'engage non piste excessif
c'est symptomatique d'autres choses
c'est juste aux maîtres d ailleurs en
disant ils sont pas si nombreux les
personnes en team ans et sont pas si
nombreuses et c'est un choix valable
parce qu'ils étaient en période de crise
que d'autres enfants en algérie je
comprends le mais ces personnes là sont
pas juste un petit masque ces personnes
là sont contre l'idée d'un gouvernement
sont comptés
un pack r d'affaires programme en plus
graves
sur le long terme que le masque est
évident mais effectivement de parler de
radicalisation le plus possible ça fait
aimer tontine si je vais parler avec une
relation malsaine c'est la relation
malsaine et souvent pas nécessairement
bassine de plus joueront le titre
vraiment moins ça se construit
tranquillement petit tombe là dedans tu
viens prix là dedans vraiment
tranquillement mais si rapidement
on apprend aux gens comment reconnaître
les signes et puis justement intime et
on tait avant que je lise l'arctique sur
l'article roman de fond de défiance sur
c'est quoi le mouvement ekin je peux si
on dit comme ça mais si je partais je
pense pas qu'à moi je serais tombé de
dames étant quelqu'un qui lit ce qu'il
fait à pied c'est ce cas précis mais
tant qu'ils qui voit partager des infos
qui est invité dans un groupe ce ils
vont peut-être en plus plus rapidement
reconnaître ce que c'est pis pour
vouloir embarquer là dedans c'est
effectivement qu'il faudra parler de ces
folles histoires comme ça existait pas
si on dit juste qu'elle s'est défoulé
qui c'est qui va avoir envie de rire et
ben j'avais tort pigeon ce que j'en sors
fait qu'on se pointer du doigt pour te
dis que tu un fou c'est pas des fous et
faute de force donné le droit aussi au
cheminement de changer d'idée j'ai
changé de dessin quoi c'est pas grave je
change d'idée constamment sur un paquet
d'avants quitte à changer d'idée sur le
masque de change et du dessin la
supposée dictature mais tu as droit de
changer d europe révolue et on discute
et on peut faire nos recherches peu
après sans avoir été convaincu par
d'autres cherchent aussi il ya vraiment
un donateur commun à tout ce qui se
passe en 2020 justement puis c'est
justement de l'apprentissage pileux
désapprentissage aussi petit autant
qu'il fallait admettre ses torts qui a
pu être dit vouloir apprendre sur le
mouvement antiraciste sur les
dénonciations qu'eux mêmes ou si on a
tous des fausses croyances le thi cong
d'intégrer qu'il faut aussi peut-être de
faire le tipi faut arrêter de dire ben
non moi je pars à 6 pdb non moi je peux
en agresseur de dire ben non moi je
prends conspirationnistes je pense
qu'ils foutent vraiment essayé
de ce fait l'examen sur toutes ses
facettes le petit peut l'être un tout
petit peu moyennement coup le dépendant
des gens super d'accord mais l'important
c'est de se donner le droit à la
réflexion puis à l'auto examen
l'enfer c'est que sa demande d'un pipe y
en ce moment je pense qu'on est tous
dans une crise où l'on cherche le temps
il la paix d'esprit pour réfléchir aux
six mois j'ai eu l'angoissé jamais
tangwa seuil avant le jeu je dors mal je
comprend puisqu'il parle je comprends
pas mes émotions je me dis moi j'ai la
chance et le privilège d'avoir d'avoir
été scène bell des ports le thé d'avoir
eu les outils et l'argent nécessaire
pour avoir une certaine paix d'esprit
les mamans monoparentales avec trop de
jeunes qu'ils ont perdue puis qui doit
nourrir leurs enfants pareil peut se
faire évincer photos vraiment je leur
demande de faire un auto examen en ce
moment même si ce que j'ai envie de
faire je peux pas où nous hélas content
je fais juste tout le temps je fais
juste tourner en rond dans toutes mes
réflexions en faisant ces discussions le
trio de tête en ce moment une banda
parental de rien de faire la vaisselle
qui écoute la patte cassée je les admire
bah oui c'est ça le talent mais aussi
c'est qui mais si sa foule savoir les
discussions les plus régulièrement
possible je pense piment mais c'est ça
le problème 6,7 of peace & love is et
ses chiens puis des fois tu as juste
envie de le déployer partir à porto rico
le wi fi c'est que quand ça te touche
personnellement tu mets ton moins 1 go
qui voudraient comprendre et le
féminisme clic et comme je veux faire un
auto examen fac là ils se mettraient à
poser plein de questions
puis mettra en doute certaines des
choses que j dis parce qu'ils touchent
pas ça les touche ça le touche pas
piller comprend pas moins qu'on va
mettre en tabarnak
moi ça va mais puise et moi c'est
vraiment ça va me demander quatre fois
plus d'énergie pour aider cette personne
n'a progressé comme quand moi je demande
à une personne noire
mais pourquoi s et c'est pourquoi c'est
grave de te demander d'où tu viens
c'est la même affaire
mais tant que nous dit ben faut discuter
avec une personne conspirationnistes
pour essayer de comprendre comment
pensent pu l'aider mais cette personne
va se braquer cap soit plus parce que ça
la touche intimement
je me demande souvent aussi mais comment
je fais pour discuter d'autres se sent
la poussée tout de suite dans des
retranchements super émotif que moi je
comprends pas parce que moi je pense je
crois poppy jogging alors on fait
comment on parle de quoi
comment la proche si j'ai vraiment
besoin truvo un cours de psychologie
honnêtement sur quelles questions je
peux reposer par un proche qui est tombé
de ce côté là de la croyance 100m tout
de suite le pousser à se braquer parce
que c'est un ange lui motif pour lui
comme moi je me braque cargo et joie
l'avocat de table merci infiniment
s'il avait je lui posais plein de
questions non mais coûte mais c'étaient
des sujets sur lesquels on peut répondre
par un bout des réponses de poser plein
de questions univers en fait c'est tu
poses des questions
premièrement nous ouais mais deuxième à
tout le monde si qu'écoutent picchi ces
questions lors il reste avec nous
pillons y pensent - veuillez pas n'est
pas une journée depuis depuis le début
de la cave il que je me suis pas mis que
j'ai pas réfléchi à quoi que ce soit au
niveau de la société puis des enjeux
sociaux t il pas une fois que je me suis
que je me suis levé avec juste aucune
remise en question a fait ça fait
longtemps à l'été puis je pense que
c'est nécessaire même si des fois c'est
sauver des réponses écrivez moi mais
d'un commentaire ces commandants de vent
il va avoir le même mouvement cessé
d'avoir commencé sauf que à chaque fois
je pense que c'est une petite victoire
on y parle d'un départ vers des six
nations mais dans deux ans pendant
quatre ans dans six ans pour que je vaux
sur une destination mais j'espère
revenir dans deux enfants c'était
vraiment moins pour cette fois ci en
liga
c'est vraiment une question si calais
qui courront le dr fukuda